ciao genova sono nicola martinelli i
produttori di parmigiano reggiano questa
sera vi racconterò di parmigiano
reggiano e di come rivoluzionare un
prodotto tipico il parmigiano reggiano è
un formaggio fatto in un pezzettino
grande così del mondo dell'italia nella
provincia di parma di reggio emilia di
modena mantova che tagliata dal po a
super poi per mi senta giorno viene nord
e pan udine bologna e tagliato dal reno
alla sinistra del regno per misano viene
alla destra non viene perché archi in
questo areale i nostri amici francesi di
air è vero c'è un terroir ci sono delle
condizioni di composizione del suolo e
di andamento climatico che fanno sì che
sulle foglie dell'arma medica che la
foraggera che le rovine che fanno latte
parmigiano reggiano mangiano crescono
tra i batteri buoni i richiami tre
amigos mano dei nomi impronunciabili per
l'approvazioni solletico state facendo
sempre più spesso guidare così l'attuale
ciclo starebbero diso specie lactis
questi tre signori devono passare dall
erba alfiero dal film la mangiatoia
dalla mangiatoia il latte e una volta
che le avete dentro le forme fermentano
le componenti del latte per darvi gli
aromi profumi tipici del parmigiano
reggiano
quindi il parmigiano reggiano si fa solo
lì tra questa ragione il cuore della
produzione di parmigiano reggiano sono
363 caseifici come dire 360 tra cantine
nella regione dello champagne che
comperano il latte da 3.093 aziende
agricole c'è 3.093 famiglie 3.093
strutture dispersi un in territorio ma
che pressavano
che governano il territorio pensate ad
esempio a tutti di sestri idrogeologici
che accadono quanto un territorio viene
governato quindi i caseifici acquistano
il latte trasformano il latte in
parmigiano reggiano e loro vendono il
parmigiano reggiano quando diventa
parmigiano reggiano cioè dodici mesi
dopo se il formaggio passo un esame
l'avrete visto arriva un signore vestito
di bianco con un martello e deve
decidere se questa forma è buona quindi
diventa parmigiano reggiano oppure no e
quindi non lo diventano lasciando la
forma chiusa perché aprirla e mangiare
formaggio sarebbe facile quindi il
concetto cos'è di tre amigos non
producono gas nel corso delle
fermentazioni quindi quando picchiate
una forma e sentite va bene se sentite o
un buco qui vuol dire che è cresciuto
qualcuno che non doveva crescere quindi
quella forma non può diventare
parmigiano reggiano i 363 vendola 12
mesi a chi ha 10 stagionatori
distributori e solo quelli quindi
arrivano comprano spaccano le forme ed i
richiami 10 bandidos quindi in realtà la
storia del parmigiano reggiano né una
guerra tra tre amigos e 10 bambino
questo sistema ha garantito per 1500
anni la crescita di un territorio per
1500 anni le famiglie in questo
territorio hanno costruito case aziende
e il territorio stato governato ma da 10
anni circa
qualcosa sta cambiando da dieci anni
stiamo perdendo progressivamente
l'artigianalità del parmigiano reggiano
per quali ragioni tre forze che si
uniscono il primo una nazione
speculativa dei dieci bambini cosa
accade
i 360 grafici comprano latte delle
graduatorie
alla fine di ogni mese danno i soldi
all'agricoltura addirittura per poter
dare soldi all'agricoltore mettono
impegno nelle banche il formaggio dopo
12 mesi quando quindi oramai di ossigeno
non ce n'è più aveva uno dei dieci
bandidos poi mette d'accordo con gli
altri nove di ciascun caseificio 14
vivendi il parmigiano reggiano a 10 ma
pace il caseificio da nove ma pace che
sa di calcio tra chi meno da 8
ovviamente i 363 morse sotto questa
stretta di liquidità cedono il
parmigiano reggiano a loro volta i 300
ragazzi fici pagano sempre meno il latte
gli agricoltori
il fenomeno che cos'è che anno dopo anno
magari qualche film che non aveva sul
solo i tre amigos viene usato e quindi
magari del latte che proprio non era
perfetto per fare il parmigiano reggiano
viene usato effetto un tantino reggiano
che perde progressivamente di
distintività rispetto agli altri
formaggi
se questo momento la seconda forza
l'allargamento dei mercati e quindi la
possibilità di trovare sugli scaffali
dei prodotti sostituti el unite alla
terza forza un consumatore completamente
differente
il consumatore parmigiano reggiano era
la massaia che lavoro faceva la
casalinga quindi aveva il dente ma dava
anche il valore del parto da una materia
prima
ma e la trasforma un prodotto finito vi
faccio i cappelletti gli aironi
oggi diamo un valore del tempo
completamente differente usciamo dal
lavoro tecnici che volevo prezzo il
formato andiamo in palestra e poi magari
comperiamo i tortellini già fatti nel
supermercato
questi tre fattori c'è il fatto di non
c'è più un consumatore così affezionato
al prodotto e vi aprono a presa intesi
mai come oggi il consumatore è attento
all'acquisto mai come oggi canali
tematici riviste nel gusto ap
mai come oggi dai valore a quello che
sta riacquistando se vuoi ti rendi conto
che quello che stai acquistando che poi
in realtà non ti serve così tanto e non
buono tanto quanto ma balordo tanto
quando un prodotto sostituto che trovo
sullo scaffale capite che quello che sta
avvenendo è una inesorabile deriva verso
una industrializzazione del prodotto più
tipico dei prodotti tipici italiani di
quello che ha reso il lavoro fu di
italiano importante nel mondo quindi
avete un prodotto che perde identità e
per starci dentro devi essere grande
grande quindi da 10 mila aziende 10 anni
fa oggi ce ne sono 3.093 che fanno latte
ben 1.500 casi fici di dieci anni fa
oggi ce ne sono 363 e non è questa
storia di diventare grande grande perché
anche a casa mia mi opa dobbiamo
diventare grandi grandi ames credeva
tanto con quello che il mio amico jack
prevost produttore di ciampa in aree
miss mi dice sempre prevista un ettaro
di vigna fa 15mila bottiglie le vende a
40 euro l'una 700mila euro di fatturato
in cantina sostanzialmente sono il mio
suo figlio tranne di
tim all'opera di ciak si porta a casa
300 mila euro netti all'anno e il
comando anni ma come fai
lui quasi un po così un po vergognoso
insieme a nicola sono fortunato
io vivo nell'area d'oro di produzione
dell'uva in america noi che viviamo
nell'area d'oro della produzione del
latte non possiamo far sì che ci sia un
modello di agricoltura differente dove
anche la famiglia il valore sociale
della famiglia e ti presenta sul
territorio con pochi animali puoi realtà
vivere una vita dignitosa
cosa si dovrebbe suonare di diverso
innanzitutto fare un parmigiano reggiano
differente c'è sotto al marchio ombrello
parmigiano reggiano sotto al marchio
campanin si dovrebbe permettere di fare
una serie di differenze e poi sarà
ovviamente il consumatore finale il
mercato decidere se un mood vale 20 euro
e un crystal ne vale 200 ma soprattutto
permettere ai 363 casi fici che magari
trovano la mia tecnica per fare quello
che vi ho detto di non finire il
dodicesimo mese nella morsa dei dieci
bandidos altrimenti tutto il lavoro
sarebbe vano e voi adesso magari
penserete si ricorda belle parole cioè
questa è una bella utopia invece vi
voglio raccontare la storia di un
imprenditore pescara marcello che invece
ha completamente rotto il meccanismo è
che ci ha insegnato qualcosa
marciano intanto a questo dovere guarda
il latte è sempre bianco ma non è tutto
uguale cioè il latte che una bobina fa
appena dopo il parto perché non
dimentichiamo che la bobina come la
donna comincia a fare lato una volta che
è nato il vitellino perché del suo punto
di vista è do da mangiare al mit e lino
il latte d'inizio lattazione è un latte
pochissimo dopo vuoi dire io entro nella
via i primi grappoli più belli per fare
il vino marcel fatto un parmigiano
reggiano fantastico da un punto di vista
organolettico usando solo quel tipo di
dante poi ovviamente lo arricchito con
degli aspetti intangibili mat.it quindi
la stessa natura di breve a una carta di
un colore verde quella di stagionatura
intermedia a una carta di colore rosso
quella sopra stagionata alla carta di
colore nero e sapete cosa accadde un
consumatore finale quando lo mangi di c
entra il punto è che non si ricorda il
cognome di marcello o il nome del
parmigiano reggiano millesimato in
questo caso ma dice mi dai il partigiano
della carta rossa mi dai il pareggio
della carta ne ha quindi noi
effettivamente riuscito
sopra questo marchio ombrello parmigiano
reggiano tecnicamente a costoro non
vengo la differente ma la roba
incredibile è come ha finanziato
l'operazione perché non è andato
assolutamente nelle banche
lui ha pensato poi fatto portare
liquidità in azienda senza indebitava ha
pensato la vendita diretta
quindi facciamo un bel punto vendita di
fronte al caseificio e marcelo che ha
fatto nei miei in canada
mi diceva sai quando si parla di eritemi
e invece di vendita diretta al
consumatore finale
il mio professore di marketing manager
mi diceva ricordate la teoria del 4 l in
un punto vendita è importante la
location la lucchese
la location è la location quindi
marcello e ve lo garantisco io l'ho
visto io c'ero ha fatto due giorni dal
mattino alle 4 alla sera alle dieci
seduto sullo sgabello davanti al suo
terrifici per capire cosa succede nella
location e sono due momenti di grande
affluenza 1 dalle 6 del mattino alle 8
un altro dalle 17 3 inter 19 c'era
evidente che lui vive in un luogo dove
le persone che passano davanti al
mattino per andare a fare colazione e
ritornavano a casa alla sera
allora lui cos'ha detto al mattino
ti do la colazione quindi ti vendo il
parmigiano ma con ti do la colazione e
alla sera ti offro l'aperitivo e così
nasce barlumeria è il tuo di due bar più
se maria non era solitamente uno spaccio
due intravisto negozio in una vetrata
enorme con tutto il latte che correva a
destra sinistra perché c'era la vetrata
su caseificio un varco di gastronomia
meraviglioso dove più passati e non
potevi far altro che innamorarti in
fondo c'era un angolo dove venivano
somministrate decorazioni con il
cappuccino che era il latte appena munto
di khorassan che erano i frumenti
dell'azienda agricola trasformata e
quindi uno entrava per spendere un euro
e 50 pollici ma questa la venivano dai
cro porto il mio cliente ma quel
formaggio libri noi pacchetti che lo
porta a casa cucina non ha speso 15 euro
succedeva anche che arrivano le massaie
a fare spesa spedito il marito al lavoro
mandato al figlio a scuola con la scusa
andare a far la spesa si prendevano
momentino per loro quindi in realtà
erano lì quelli col cornetto
buccino marcelo faceva trovare tutta la
bibliografia del settore donna moderna
che vanity fair
il successo è stato talmente grande che
marcello aperto altri due punti vendita
nei due anni successivi ma segnale uno
dentro un outlet con 150 negozi di
vestiti è un altro dentro un ipermercato
con di fronte la piattaforma alimentarci
al concetto era ti porto le aziende
agricole in città c'è tua fas per me che
ho una cattedrale nel deserto e tu devi
fidarti suoi fare trenta chilometri per
andare a prendere un pezzo di formaggio
no tu vai normalmente a fare spesa di
vestiti mi trovi formalmente a fare
spesa alimentare mi trovi con il latte
che diventa il cappuccino
il fumetto diventa il pane le scottone a
romagnole che diventano delle tartare
degli hamburger due bourguignonne e da
chi c'è stato un flusso a monte da parte
delle persone quindi nel caseificio dopo
un qualche anno di sperimentazione è
stato aperto il caseificio della musica
che adesso sostanzialmente un luogo dove
avviene una festa nell'aria in versione
voi non ci crederete questo locale ha
gareggiato il 9 di ottobre a ibiza per
diventare uno dei locali più importanti
del mondo io quando dico marcia ma ma ma
non è ancora fatta marcia tutti ridico
che oggi ci sono dei giovani che vengono
a ballare in un caseificio mangiù roma
il posto e anche veramente cioè
fighissimo come si dice dalle mie parti
meno mi dice nicola cosa c'è di
differente era quello che faceva
mio nonno quando era giovane insomma
marcello ha realizzato se soglio il suo
di marcello era quello di fare il suo
parmigiano reggiano con il suo nome e
venderlo con una redditività che gli
permettesse di crescere in un modo
solido e sganciarsi da quel meccanismo
di cui vi dicevo però marcelo c'è anche
insegnato una cosa intanto che anche nel
2015 è possibile realizzare dei sogni
che è possibile realizzare i sogni
scarpinato dei meccanismi che sembrano
intoccabili
nulla di più intoccabile del prodotto
tipico più vecchio più antico d'italia
1500 anni con un impalcatura di dieci
bandidos che ho passati da loro ho
passati da loro per attenzione marcello
c'è anche insegnato che per realizzare
il sogno non solo ci vuole sogno come si
diceva prima e come qualcheduno di più
importanti diceva stefan restyling
quindi non permettiamo mai a nessuno di
togliersi quel sentimento che abbiamo
naturalmente quando siamo bambini perché
quando sono bambini tutti abbiamo un
sogno quindi non facciamolo morire o non
siamo come alibi per giustificare in
realtà i nostri insuccessi ma l'altra
cosa che ci ha insegnato marcello
e che le cose si possono fare se pensi
in modo differente rispetto ai
meccanismi consueti e l'altra cosa è
l'unico che c'è sempre
non lancio comes for free che vuol dire
che nessun pasto ti vien dato
gratuitamente
infatti vi posso garantire che marcello
non l'ho mai visto in giro a perdere
tempo ma l'altra cosa è che ho capito
che questo modello può essere nei suoi
principi replicato gli altri produttori
parmigiano reggiano possono seguire la
stessa strada per trovare la loro vita a
fare un parmigiano reggiano differente e
per finanziare un modo diverso e la
stessa cosa può essere completamente
trasferita anche per gli altri prodotti
di obi ed igp che oggi stanno vivendo un
qualcosa di drammatico come se questo
invece che sono un punto di forza fosse
un grande punto di debolezza ma non solo
questo c'è anche insegnato che
un'azienda agricola basata su dei valori
forti
la famiglia la tutela del territorio
vado a ballare in un caseificio e mi
diverto c'è un'agricoltura basata su dei
valori normali senza dover diventare la
grandissima azienda agricola la
grandissima multinazionale è possibile
io penso che questa è veramente non
un'agricoltura 2.0
ma un'agricoltura 3.0 e questa è
l'agricoltura che io voglio vivere
grazie